in Florida there is no doubt about the
results of a series of big wins for
Republicans Governor Ron DeSantis sailed
to Victory and sailed is the word here
in his re-election campaign beating
former Governor Charlie Chris in his
victory speech last night DeSantis
thanked a long list of supporters but he
did not mention Donald Trump the former
president watched the results at his
Mar-A-Lago Resort and called it a great
evening but he also tried to warn the
governor against running again anytime
soon our Tony decope was in Miami where
he's been covering the Florida campaign
his home state Tony good morning to you
based on your three meals yesterday
you're not surprised that this was the
outcome
no good morning my friend we definitely
saw this one coming and good morning to
all you at home the midterms are of
course a mile marker for America but
they are also let's be real here a
starting gun for candidates hoping to
make a White House run in 2024. so here
comes former president Donald Trump
already teasing that big announcement
quote unquote next week and he's firing
an election day warning shot at one of
his biggest potential rivals in 2024 and
one of last night's biggest winners
with a big night in Florida Freedom is
here to stay
and a double-digit win over Democrat
Charlie Crist we not only won election
we have Rewritten the political map
Ron DeSantis kept a dizzying four-year
rise
narrowly elected as governor in 2018 now
widely talked up as a potential White
House contender in 2024 among his gains
last night more than 80 000 votes in
Miami's traditionally blue Dade County
and compared to four years ago he picked
up voters Statewide in nearly every
demographic including women and Latino
voters a group he lost by 10 points last
time but on maybe the biggest day of Ron
desantis's political career former
president Donald Trump held his own
election night event tallying what he
claimed were his victories of candidates
he endorsed 80 wins and three losses is
that good
and in a series of interviews the former
president took credit for DeSantis being
Governor at all I got him the nomination
he didn't get it I got it I thought that
he could have been more gracious but
that's up to him in comments to the Wall
Street Journal he also called the
possible DeSantis White House run a
mistake
and then a warning if he did run I will
tell you things about him that won't be
very flattering I know more about him
than anybody other than perhaps his wife
who is really running his campaign
and when I read that line guys it really
did take me back to 2016. it feels like
a callback in fact to 2016. that was of
course when Donald Trump used any means
necessary from insults to innuendo to
clear a field of GOP contenders
including by the way another Florida
Governor that would be Jeb Bush and
another of last night's Big Winners
Marco Rubio as for what Ron DeSantis is
thinking this morning we just don't know
the words Donald Trump and white house
they did not appear in his big speech
last night guys
it is interesting Tony that Donald Trump
would accuse him of not being gracious
and then say words like that we thank
you very much